11h30 précises ce matin monsieur messmer
arrive à roissy et pénètre dans le grand
hall de l'aéroport
c'est à cet instant que ce produit
l'incident une bombe fumigène lancé par
un jeune homme provoque quelques
secondes d'affolement les policiers se
précipitent et maîtrise le jeune
manifestant qui se réclament du groupe
action jeunesse un mouvement d'extrême
droite à peine retardé monsieur messmer
et le cortège officiel commence une
visite qui sera rapide du bâtiment
central celui qui se situe au coeur du
parking le fameux camembert puis seul en
voiture le premier ministre fait le tour
des pistes et des installations annexes
il passera près de concorde arrivé la
veille pour l'occasion à midi monsieur
messmer est de retour dans l'un des
périphériques choisi pour la cérémonie
d'inauguration
une cérémonie volontairement brève et
sobre cinq jours à peine après la
catastrophe d'ermenonville dans les mois
et peut-être dans les années qui
viennent
le transport aérien dans le monde
continuera de souffrir de la hausse des
prix du pétrole
sa progression sera plus lente des
escales et certains vols pourront être
supprimés et déjà diverses mesures
d'économie ont été arrêtés mais en dépit
des difficultés le développement des
transports aériens ne sera pas arrêté
parce que les voyages aériens
correspondre aux goûts aux rêves et aux
besoins des hommes par cb nous pouvons
voir se profiler concorde cet aéroport
et cet avion ne sont pas liés seulement
par la beauté de leur ligne l'un et
l'autre expriment une même ambition
celle d'un pays qui a voulu d'abord qui
a appris ensuite à épouser son siècle